[Music]
as we head into the dog days of summer I
want to get you guys up to speed on some
behind the scenes happenings as well as
tell you a bit about my plans for the
near future before I do that I quickly
want to address my conversation with
patreon CEO jack conte from earlier this
week I think that this chat as much as
anything that we've done here gets to
the heart of what I've tried to do with
the Rubin report for the past two years
Jack and I had an honest conversation
about new media and personal liberty
couched around the issue that I care
most about free speech I hope that
whether you came away from the interview
agreeing with Jack or not that you got a
better understanding of the complexities
and contradictions that we all face
whether you're a creator a CEO or a
supporter of online content as I
mentioned time and time again I believe
it's vital to occasionally put down your
phone disconnect from the grid and
reconnect with the real world this is
something I've tried to incorporate into
my life as much as possible but usually
it's much harder than it should be the
constant need to be online and in the
discussion whatever that discussion is
can be incredibly inspiring and valuable
but it can also be incredibly draining
and time-sucking beyond just doing the
Rubin report I've been trying to work on
a book for the past year as well as
catch up on some side projects while
also setting a little time for some
mental clarity with this in mind I want
to lay out the rest of my summer for you
this week on the show we have British
columnist and commentator Katie Hopkins
who's sure to trigger many of those who
are trigger Abul and then I head to New
York City to do the Greg Gutfeld show on
Saturday after that I'll be truly
experiencing one of the highlights of my
professional career as I interview
Richard Dawkins at the 92nd Street Y in
New York City the event sold out almost
immediately before I even had a chance
to mention it to you guys but the fine
folks at the Y are giving us the video
of the whole two-hour interview which
will be shot in from about 2,000 people
and we'll be posting it right here on
our channel next week after this
interview with Dawkins I'll be going off
the grid completely completely for the
rest of the summer until September 5th
the day after Labor Day if you're not
though you will be getting new Rubin
Report episodes every week we've already
taped interviews with Professor GAD sad
columnist
Bentsen economist Pia Milani and
chairman of the Iran Institute your own
Brook since we've taped these interviews
already I can promise you that you're
going to dig all of them and each
episode is truly different from one
another what we may lose in filming and
releasing in the same week I promise you
that you'll get back with the continued
focus on ideas rather than news cycles
while we will post all these videos as
scheduled I will not be on social media
of any kind until September 5th that's
right I am NOT going to tweet I am NOT
going to post on Facebook share anything
on Instagram or anywhere else we're
going to automate a couple posts in
advance so that we can promote our
weekly episodes but I won't be sharing
anything else checking mentions or even
reading the news I look forward to
having some relaxation time on the beach
but for the most part I'll be spending
most of my time during this break
catching up on reading exercising and
most importantly focusing on this book
which is long overdue basically I'm not
going to look at screens of any kind
except for when I'm writing this book
I'm sure people try to talk to me about
the news but I'm going to do everything
in my power to truly shut down and
really escape from the day-to-day
play-by-play madness yes I will miss
some Trump tweets I'll miss some pho
outrages and I'll miss whatever else
happens in the world but I do have a
suspicion that the world will keep
spinning without me and at the same time
I also have a suspicion that I'll be
better off for this break afterward it
seems kind of crazy to take a vacation
and truly escape the web these days but
that was pretty much the norm only a
decade ago if the world does end while
I'm done I suppose it'll have to end
without me live tweeting it more
importantly than anything else though I
just want to thank all of you who not
only watch this show but share it with
friends and family and who are having
these conversations in your own lives
there is absolutely no doubt that the
issues that we're talking about here are
taking root in the real world and that
real change is on the horizon if I
didn't think that we could change the
world by having these honest
conversations on the importance of free
speech and individual liberty I assure
you that I would do something else after
all it's never too late for me to pick
up my MBA dreams before I sign off
though I want to give a special shout
out to all of you who have supported us
on patreon and PayPal since we went
independent about 14 months ago you guys
have true
Huli help me make my dreams come true
and now you're giving me in my crew a
little breathing room allowing me to
work on this book and helping us all
take it to the next level I already have
a packed schedule of speaking gigs and
college events coming up this fall and I
look forward to coming back more focused
and invigorated and ever before without
your support not only couldn't we do
this show at the professional level with
which we do it but there's certainly no
way I could take a few weeks to clear
the mind and plot the future maybe some
of you will join me on this technology
free couple weeks but for those of you
who don't I know you'll enjoy everything
we've cooked up for you while we're gone
again thank you all for your support and
generosity and as we enter season 3 of
the Reuben report in September I promise
you this is just the beginning
[Music]
you